from bonding with a fish for decades
to preserving 150 year old shipwrecks
any dive can turn into an adventure
take the plunge into these four
incredible underwater stories
it's not very many people really know
but the great lakes has thousands of
shipwrecks
in wisconsin for sure we know we have
750
historic shipwreck losses my name is
caitlin zandt and i'm a maritime
archaeologist with the wisconsin
historical society
i would say the main goal of what we do
in maritime archaeology is to preserve
our maritime history and also the
history of the united states in general
the ships are quite sturdy but they've
also been underwater for
up to 150 years
our shipwrecks don't disappear over time
like they do in the oceans the fresh
water that's very cold actually does a
really good job at preserving these
shipwrecks
one of the really great things about
lake michigan that makes it really
unique is the fact that you do have
fresh clear water you can see many times
especially on deep wrecks 100 to 150
feet
when you were down there looking at a
shipwreck you start to think of all the
sailors that sailed on it or if it was a
passenger ship the passengers that
happened to be on it
you can still find pieces of
clothing in certain areas buttons shoes
and so that really gives insight to the
lives of these sailors
there's definitely a little bit of a
thrill of discovery
when we go down on a ship even on a ship
that we know we think we know what it is
there's still always that little
sense of excitement that you're going to
find something that no one else has seen
before
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
freediver to me is a pioneer
we're all experimenting in something
that has not been the main trust of
humanity until now
my name is aaron solomons
i'm a free dive instructor trainer from
ada i specialize in coaching athletes
who want to do national records or world
records
you've got to kick in your dive reflexes
breathe up a little bit uh breathing
about
as you do just before you went to sleep
then one big breath turn over and go
from the moment that you leave the
surface
the blood is beginning to leave the
peripheries and migrate towards the
so-called noble organs
then you start to sink faster and faster
once you're free falling it's pure
pleasure it's an incredible sensation of
restfulness
you're going down and the colors change
you go down from a clear blue here
to a darker blue
and to
a purple twilight
and then finally into total blackness
then we have a rude awakening we hit the
play and then we turn around and we have
to work a bit harder coming up
as you come up you're working less hard
because buoyancy is returning
and then it's like a rebirth you're
coming back into the light
the whole process is one pleasure
and a terrific sense of adventure and
achievement
usually changes some switches
all the things that i thought were
impossible
all the things that i thought were not
achievable by me
are
if that's achievable what else isn't
achievable and that opens a whole
pandora's box
so it's quite an experience freedom
[Music]
ikai
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
industry
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Music]
you